- So fans have noted much less sex scenes
in season 2 compared to
season 1, here's the thing,
the sex scene that does exist,
(Kelly laughing)
I was like, "Hey."
♪ Hey ♪
All right, spoiler alert,
well, first of all,
before your spoiler alert,
I look like straight up out of the 80s
because we're doing an 80s episode
and although I kinda like
my hair and my makeup
so I would do this now so I
don't know why I'm apologizing,
but spoiler alert people,
I'm about to dish all my opinions
on "Bridgerton Season 2",
that's right, if you
have not watched it yet,
that's your problem, you
should probably tune out now
'cause I'm about to talk about all of it
but for everyone else that has,
you know, you are caught up,
please pull up a chair, put the kettle on
'cause I'm about to talk all the tea
on "Bridgerton Season 2", and I loved it
and I watched it all in one
day, night, day slash night,
I couldn't stop,
(Kelly chuckling)
it's good.
(bright music)
I love this show so much, I'm very in it.
Just shout-out to Andy, he
made this, look at this,
this is amazing, it looks like it,
it looks like "Lady Whistledown's
Society Papers", come on.
"Dearest gentle reader,"
this is my Julie Andrews.
(all laughing)
I am like Meryl Streep with accents.
"Did you miss me?"
Okay, so "Bridgerton Season
2" is out now on Netflix
and it was a delicious season,
we love it, we love it,
I'm so excited about it.
(Kelly sighing)
There is just so much
greatness though with this.
I'm gonna be honest with you,
I didn't think that I could like season 2
like even as much as season
1 'cause season 1 was so good
but I kinda like season 2
even better, like it was,
(Kelly chuckling)
it was so good and I didn't
see it coming, I was like,
"Anthony, why are we doing
a whole season on Anthony?"
And I was kinda like,
(Kelly babbling)
and then I could not stop watching it,
cut to I'm like the
president of his fan club,
I love Anthony anyway,
Anthony, oh, sorry, Anthony,
I'm not classy so it's just like Anthony.
(Kelly chuckling)
(bright music)
Oh my God, I'm not good at synopsis,
in 60 seconds I can't do anything.
"Bridgerton" is so good,
okay so there's like,
you know, there's that character,
like Anthony, the brother,
and he comes in and you think,
"Oh my God, he's gotta get
it, he's gotta get a vi,
he's the Viscount, he's
gotta get a Viscount test,"
and so anyway, he was like,
"Who, which girl will
be it in the season?"
And then like all the sudden
there's the new people,
the Sharmas that come back into town
and it's just amazing
because then the older sister catches him,
like talking like guy talk,
and so she totally knows
who he is, like deep down,
and she gives him so much
(beep) the whole show,
it's amazing, and she's so smart
and she's so different for
the last, like, Daphne,
the last character, because she
is like more of like a bold,
like older sister, she's
looking out, you're kinda like,
"What's the backstory there?"
And there's a backstory, and
anyway, I don't like Portia,
I don't like that character,
I don't, I'm like,
there's this whole other
thing that I'm just like,
"Ugh, you know what?
karma," but anyway it's really good
even how she handles that at the end,
it's, you know what it is?
Is its tension, who doesn't love tension?
I thrive off tension,
it's just a nice thing.
(all laughing)
Nothing in has to
happen, just the tension.
(tense music)
♪ Hey ♪
You're gonna love it.
(bright music)
Thoughts on Anthony as the new male lead,
like, you know, the first season,
I liked Anthony in the first one,
but like kinda was just kinda like,
♪ People, people ♪
Like, you know, I could have
picked him out of the lineup
but it wasn't my favorite
character obviously
'cause I was focused on Duke Hastings
and then season 2 happens,
which I think this is brilliant,
how they're doing all these
different perspectives
and stories from different characters,
I am in love with Anthony,
Anthony, whatever.
I almost like, literally, I
love their tension more so
than I loved Duke Hastings
and Daphne's, I'm just saying.
(bright music)
Thoughts on the new
female leads, I love Kate,
I think that she is so, I
think, I mean Edwina is awesome,
she's kinda gotta be that sister
'cause in order for Kate to
be able to be the other role
and have what she's doing
in that relationship
and with the writers,
I'm sure they had to have the
different kinda perspectives
but she's more the sweet one
and has kinda been taking
care of her whole life
and I don't really ever like,
oh, she does a beautiful job acting,
I just mean I don't relate at all to that,
I like the one that has to kinda struggle
and I like that kind of, you
know, heroine in the show so,
Kate is great, she's smart,
she's bold, she's funny,
very sarcastic, and
she loves some tension.
(intense music)
(crew members laughing)
Tension is the word of the day.
(Kelly chuckling)
(bright music)
So thoughts on this scandalous
love triangle in season 2,
is there a triangle?
I mean, I know that Edwina's there
but she's kinda like that person
that, like, you're on a,
you know, out with friends
and it's like happens to be three of you
but really you're just like
this person's just here
'cause it's really about
the two and it's yeah,
'cause she's great like I said
and possibly has a prince
in her future whatever
'cause at the end, if you
saw that and if you didn't,
(Kelly chuckling)
sorry.
But I like Edwina
and I do like that they
didn't pass Edwina off
for like just some kind
of, you know, floaty girl,
she's still at the end found her boldness
and held everybody kinda at
the fire for their actions
and stuff like that, I
did like her in the end,
her character kinda grew on me,
she kinda became more of like
a woman instead of a girl.
I feel like it's not
really a triangle though,
it's just a A to B line, is what it is,
and it is directly from Anthony
to Kate and it is awesome
and then in-between is tension.
(intense music)
(crew members laughing)
Yeah.
Is this not the hottest
line in the entire season?
"Anthony Bridgerton, you
are the bane of my existence
and the object of all my desires,"
(paper crackling)
That scene when Kate came
chasing after Anthony
and they went in that room
and they got real close
and he was in her ear and I was like,
♪ Oh my God ♪
And she, I was like, hey,
♪ Hey ♪
It was, I was like, "What is
ha, that, if you like tension,
(intense music)
(Kelly chuckling)
It's so good, it's so good.
(bright music)
So fans have noted much less sex scenes
in season 2 compared to
season 1, here's the thing,
you don't miss that and first of all,
the sex scene that does exist,
and then you're provided
with like more details
'cause whenever she has her
like memory of it, I'm like,
I literally rewind, I was like,
"I don't remember that part."
(all laughing)
I was like, and I rewound, and I was like,
"That wasn't in the initial
out-in-the-gardens moment,"
and then I was like, "You gave us more?
You gave us like memories of
one of your shows albeit?"
Anyway, so it was just,
it's a good, it's worth it,
because you know why?
It's not about just like,
some of the mystery's nice,
the tension is nice, you
know, then it's done,
then you've done it,
and it's like, you know,
there's never like the brush
of, "Ooh, what might happen?"
You know, and here's the
thing I like about this season
that was different from last season,
I was a little more of like,
I love Jane Austen kinda stuff
so I'm like, it was a little
more of like just tension,
like there wasn't as much,
well, that library scene with
the ladder in the first one,
♪ Hey ♪
(Kelly chuckling)
I love that one but there
wasn't really as much,
if there was stuff like that, yes
but it's more of like a lot of like,
"Ooh, brushed by glance
here, duh, duh, duh,
oh it's wrong but it's right," so nice.
Anyway, so you're gonna love this season.
(bright music)
I love how they do the music too
because I remember the
first season I was listening
and I was like, "Is that like
Ariana Grande or something?"
I was like listening and
I was like, "Wait, what?"
'Cause I could tell
what it was, the melody,
and I love that they do
that, they take modern music
and they just put an orchestra to it,
like a string with quartet
and it's like so cool
and so beautiful.
Oh, I love that they
used "Dancing On My Own",
I thought that was really cool, Robyn,
I thought that was cool,
they did "You Oughta Know",
they did Alanis which I was like,
"You just brought Alanis
Morissette into "Bridgerton",
how does this get better?"
The tension.
(bright music)
How many sips of tea would
I give "Bridgerton Season 2"
out of five?
I'd give it, if we're
gonna look, I'm gonna pour,
so this is cute, you're fancy.
I'd know, I know I'm about to go do a show
but look I was also a waitress
so I feel like I've got it.
How many sips of tea out of
five for "Bridgerton Season 2",
not five, seven, Monica-level
seven from "Friends",
like seven lumps of sugar,
seven spots of tea, seven,
just, yes, let me know in the comments,
your favorite part of season 2
and subscribe to my scrumptious channel,
I bid you farewell, it's you're welcome.
(Kelly laughing)
(crew members laughing)
(bright music)